after 18 months of war with Ukraine
Russia's thirst for artillery ammunition
is insatiable
Western military sources put Russian
ammo expenditure for last year and
roughly 10 and a half million rounds
some simple calculations show that over
10 months of conflict in 2022 the
average daily use of artillery
ammunition was 35 000 rounds a day
that means its armed forces have used
over 9 million rounds so far in 2023 and
the war shows no sign of slowing down
Russia's economy is still not officially
on a war footing its defense industry is
only able to produce up to 2 million
rounds a year meaning there is a massive
shortfall in its stocks of artillery
ammunition rockets for its multiple
launch systems and mortar ammunition
North Korea has huge stockpiles of just
this kind of ammunition and this will be
a core part of the discussions between
Kim and Putin the question remaining
just how much ammunition can North Korea
spare
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera